si petit et déjà au cœur des débats
samedi dernier la ville de Trappes
organisait son premier rendez-vous entre
professionnels de la petite enfance et
parents l'occasion d'échanger sur les
rythmes et les espaces de vie du jeune
enfant je travaille en crèche et c'est
vrai que c'était c'est très intéressant
par rapport à mon travail au niveau des
enfants et c'est vrai que ça nous fait
beaucoup de rappel aussi sur ce qu'on a
appris avant puis bon on se rend compte
que c'est loin d'être la réalité
un personnel trop peu nombreux pour
accueillir toujours plus d'enfants et
c'est la liberté d'épanouissement des
tout-petits qui se trouve amputés de
plus auxiliaire animateur et assistante
maternelle sont trop peu formés à
l'éducation des 0,6 ans
collective entre différents services ça
peut être intéressant qu'on est tous la
même pédagogie que la même démarche
vis-à-vis des enfants
respecter le rythme de enfant
de faire tout ce soir en même temps pour
faire une activité c'est pas forcément
bon laissez l'enfant jouer et être
initiateur de son jeu pour lui donner
confiance en lui plutôt que d'être
encadré et orienté par les adultes c'est
le souhait des professionnels présents
ce jour-là la France est en retard sur
certaines des questions en tout cas sur
l'éducation et sur le fait de
laisser les plus petits jouer le plus
longtemps possible dès qu'il
franchissent je dirais la porte de
l'école en fait ils sont formatés pour
pouvoir répondre aux demandes des
enseignants et de pouvoir être préparé
pour leur enseignement ils deviennent
très tôt des élèves changer les modes
d'accueil des enfants et les
individualiser ce sont les pistes de
travail de la ville de Trappes qui
propose d'autres débats tout au long du
mois de février